two investigations are underway over
whether cadets and midshipmen
flashed a white power sign on live tv
they were seen making the okay sign
behind a reporter before
saturday's army navy game the gesture
has been adopted by
white supremacists to signify a w and a
p
for white power david martin is at the
pentagon david how are west point in the
u.s naval academy responding to this
well the u.s military academy at west
point
says it is examining the intent of the
cadets to determine
if any administrative action is required
the naval academy
says depending on what the investigation
finds those involved will be held
accountable
video from espn's college game day
saturday shows three cadets and
midshipmen
flashing the hand sign some of them
making a point to
show their hand to the camera this
meaningfulness and the significance
extends well beyond just when the two
teams play each other
the hand gesture is similar to the okay
song up 4 or down 40.
they play their guts out but the
anti-defamation league's jonathan
greenblatt
says lately it's been used by white
extremists
including the christ church shooter in
new zealand and by white nationalists at
a portland oregon rally in
august that was a white power gesture
white power being kind of the expression
often used
by right-wing extremists to symbolize
and kind of speak to
their belief in white supremacy but
sometimes the hand signal is also
reportedly popular among junior military
members
as part of the circle game where if
another person looks at it
they get punched greenblatt says it's
too soon to say
what these young cadets were doing and
so again i can't ascertain the motive of
these kids
i'm glad that the universities will
investigate
this will allow the universities to hold
a conversation about
issues of tolerance issues of respect
issues of diversity issues of equity
a member of the coast guard was caught
last year
flashing a similar hand signal in the
background of a television interview
during the aftermath of hurricane
florence he was reprimanded and removed
from hurricane duty
tony david thank you very much i mean
intent really is the question here
what are they trying to get across it
does have two meanings so it'll be very
interesting to see what they find out
and if you were playing a punching game
why were you doing it on live tv that's
that's something all right david thank
you very much